buddy welcome to the conan haiti live
Q&A yeah thank you for joining us
Facebook YouTube and twitch say hello to
writers who's a arroyo Mike Sweeney
Jesse Gaskell of course Conan O'Brien
Turner Brian everybody no one's clapping
except for me Wow a lot of people
getting fired after this can't wait
uh guys we're gonna talk about again I
hate to break it
you were always always yelling during
and I'm so far before he said asking a
technical question yes is that because
you're afraid they won't hear you maybe
they won't unless you yell right I'm
just it's a question for people watching
right now on their various devices
does he come across as sweaty that's
great god what's seeming like to people
at home so deep insecurity covered by
white hair and and a lot of makeup
makeup they actually put makeup on me
for this okay don't blame it on white
hair okay thank you guys if you guys
missed our haiti episode on saturday
night at 10:00 p.m. 9:00 central shame
on you and you can watch it all team
cocoa calm / haiti along with some
amazing extras including conan speaking
to the live audience after the show you
had a lot of great things to say and in
case you weren't in that audience you
can ask us your questions right now so
please do let's start with the obvious
question how did you decide to go to
haiti that was a pretty quick turnaround
yes the president made some disparaging
comments about as some African countries
and specifically hating famously refer
to them as [ __ ] holes that upset a lot
of people just normal citizens and
people with common sense and so I think
it was he said that on Thursday night so
Friday I've had time to kind of knock
around and then I think on Saturday I
thought let's go to Haiti and so I
quickly emailed Mike Sweeney and Jeff
Ross our producer and he's out buy
sweaters very old man it's cold in 80
degrees that's Phil so we
I just emailed those guys and said
should we go to Haiti I mean let's go to
hey is there a reason we don't go to
Haiti I mean immediately and they said
that sounds like a good idea
so Sweeney Jeff Ross and a few of us met
on Sunday and we all said let's do it
and then we arranged to double tape
during the week so that we would still
make our quota of shows and that enabled
us to get out of town on Wednesday night
and arrive in Haiti early Thursday
morning start shooting and then we left
on Sunday and then the true heroes of
the story Mike Sweeney Jesse Casco Jose
Arroyo they had to take all of his
footage and edit it together into a
cohesive show while I went back to doing
these shows the weekly shows and then we
would look at edits at night and discuss
things and we turned it all around and
screened it for an audience Thursday
night so when you think about it that's
the fastest we've ever turned around a
travel show ever
that's and and these guys deserve the
lion's share of the credit by that I
mean I get 80% that's my that's my
interpretation of the lion's share not
good at getting grants us on YouTube
says he likes your jacket co-sponsor
there we go Francis could be a boy or a
girl could be the or or multi-gender
Francis was my grandfather's name that's
why say that maybe it's a comment from
the great but anyway yeah this is a I
like this jacket because it's a plane a
jean jacket but then this came on came
with me on the trip to Mexico City and
so I have a Mexico and America and flag
pin and I also have this little
medallion of Trotsky most people think
who died in Mexico City and most people
look at it and think it's a Borat pin
people think I'm a big bore ash man and
I say well I I liked Borat but know this
this is Trotsky got an ice pick in the
head in 1940 courtesy of Stalin history
lesson Wow sorry back to that was some
Grammys last night
Madeline Sims asked how much sleep did
you get on the trip exactly we got the
lion's share
you know lion service Lee I got 80% of
the seat yeah I have to say on this one
we didn't do too badly sometimes it
feels like we are awake all the time but
this you know it at night there was one
night we went out and I danced in a club
where and we did a lot of shooting at
night but mostly things get pretty quiet
in the court of prints at night and we
so we would go to bed because we were
exhausted and get a pretty decent
night's sleep
the time difference was only three hours
so that wasn't too bad yeah yeah so they
usually you think about where else we've
been we been to Korea we've been to the
Middle East we've we've been to these
places where our body clocks are
completely messed up not the case in the
Caribbean and rum puts you right to
sleep
Sweeney and Jesse how do you put
together such as such a giant show in
such short notice how do you get your
arms around a country in basically three
days well it's an island
it's happen I'll there yeah it's my land
that was cut in half so that right there
right
cuts it way down so and we knew that we
had everyone said the traffic was
insanely bad so right we decided to
really we stayed in port-au-prince so we
decided to do all all of our shooting
report yeah yeah there was talk about
going up north where there are these
beautiful historic sites and we just
didn't have time so we had to we had to
we mention them yeah we got we bought
beautiful shots we didn't have time to
go just did it we only we really only
shot three days that's amazing the
fourth day was for travels so you're
kind of under the gun that way that's
incredible and it and we always do a lot
of research but we have a local team of
production team that helps out a ton and
we
a really good one you're a great time
yeah
shout out to Natalie and Mary yeah
Maggie straight and you know guide us to
okay this is really where locals would
go yeah place where people hang out
we're gonna you know get a lot of foot
traffic there and yeah be able to meet
people we always totally rely on we find
we always end up with really great
people in each location
no yes and then we really rely and they
they're always great yes kind of very in
sync and they never disappoint Kota
Michael on YouTube asks please dispel
some of the untruths about Haiti what
was something that surprised you
visiting Haiti near ago wow this is not
like I thought okay one of the big ones
is that I think many people have long
held this belief that it's just chaos in
Haiti right it's because predominantly
the media coverage in Haiti is about
disasters and extreme poverty and
they've they've had more than their
share of both and so there's this sense
I think people have that oh my god if
you're in Haiti you know you're just
it's just dealing with total chaos and
and and violence and it must be kind of
scary absolutely untrue it was a lot of
those things are that are said about
Haiti are extremely exaggerated there is
you know some terrible poverty there and
they did suffer an absolutely
devastating earthquake in 2010 which
they're still trying to recover from but
just a lot of beautiful people it was
you know we traveled around we we met I
think we got to visit so many different
places in and around Port au Prince and
talk to so many people and I don't know
just felt very comfortable and welcome
yeah just about everywhere and you know
I I like to say the biggest thing I
learned after this trip in my opinion is
that I've been to many places in the
world we were visiting Israel and the
West Bank we had a chance at one point
to go
to the Syrian border and look into Syria
and had the experience of thinking I
don't know how this gets solved this
this problem feels unfixable intractable
I don't know how to get solved but Haiti
feels like a country that that problems
can can be solved and actually could be
I think that country could be vastly
improved in the next 20 years with some
you know if they get some assistance and
I learn a lot of Haitians who say we
want to do it ourselves but you got the
feeling that Oh a lot of problems here
like infrastructure and and can be fixed
I think there's a lot that's there that
can be done to actually make Haiti a
much better place in the next 15 20
years yeah it feels like the pieces are
all there and they'll just eventually
get them - gets a gorgeous it's a
gorgeous town we were stunned and this
you know all this undeveloped coastline
and and you feel like if they had more
internal good road system yeah really
great Jesse what surprised you about
Haiti um I mean I what the thing that I
kept hearing from people we met was that
the American media never shows the
positive yes parts of Haiti and and I
realized that that had also permeated my
own perceptions too that we are so used
to seeing like you know rubble from the
earthquake or there's like one photo of
a river of trash that I think a lot of
that gets reposted a lot and being there
I was like no this I mean it feels like
traveling in a lot of the other parts of
the Caribbean or in Latin America and I
and it was it was gorgeous and and also
just the I mean the people were really
really awesome
we everyone we met had like these
insights on you know the global economy
and this was just people like walking in
a Plaza who would be able to expound on
there's so many if you see that you see
in a special but I'll just stop someone
and they'll say Oh where's the camera
and then they'll give this their sorta
coat they give this amazing articulate
speech
that almost feels rehearse that they've
been doing in the mirror and it's
beautiful and in nuanced anyway okay wow
it's a whole nation of people that are
ready to give a very impressive time how
many Americans could I mean yeah like if
you went to Hollywood and Vine yeah yes
my turban with a fanny pack with a worn
fanny pack
no there was so much passion a point of
passion about Haiti before the three
days we were preparing yeah of people
coming out and and you could tell it
must be a special place because yeah
people felt so strongly about it as a
country and about the people let's play
something else which is it many more I
think several Haitians independently
said to me oh you're not going to show
the beaches are you that's a little bit
of a chip they have on their shoulder
that media comes to Haiti and they show
the trash they show the collapsed
buildings they show the broken-down cars
and they don't show some of the most
beautiful undeveloped unspoiled
coastline in the Caribbean and so we
made a point of saying we're you know
we're gonna go to the beach so we we
went up north a bit north of Port au
Prince when we went to this amazing
beach and and showed the beach and I
think you know and we we took a photo of
me floating in the water yes you know
and people and and I said this is Haiti
to this is also Haiti and I think that
flipped some people out I was like you
know you're pretending that's hidden no
I'm not
this is absolutely yeah beautiful but
the media doesn't show that that's true
and yeah one you know it's speaking
about how impassioned the Haitians were
one of my favorite points of the trip
was when we went to a park call called
plasti boy a and a crowded gather do you
guys want to speak a little bit about
what happened there we were doing some
analysts read stuff talking to James
verno actually who's in the special we
were Farallon we just gotten into the
park those the first day yeah we were
stay we'd only had like 90 minutes of
sleepers no no and we we had just gotten
into the park
not much it happened yet and I'm used to
angry crowds for my children I'm used to
experiencing it know this was very
different you know you usually go out
and people are excited that you're there
shooting or they know who you are and
this is obviously a very different
situation they don't know who I am and
they were mad and you can see it it's a
very real raw moment yeah and we decided
let's go over there and talk to them and
fortunately we had an interpreter who
was trying to explain one of the things
that you don't see on the special is
that they started showing some of my
comedy that we had done a few nights
before
nothing quiets a crowd down it was
actually a piece that we had done with
Lew Lewis our interpreter where we had
done that before we went to Haiti that
where I'm think that he's interpreting
for me in Creole and he's actually
deriding me and making fun of me and
they hate the Haitian crowd saw this and
they saw that oh this guy he has a TV
show where he let a Haitian person mock
him in Creole and they they calmed down
a bit and then I had a speech you can
see that part that I delivered terribly
blame the jetlag and my lack of and but
they could you could see that they got
what I was trying to do yes that's one
of my favorite segments because you see
that the essence of so many of these
issues is go there yeah put yourself in
the same space as them listen you don't
talk over them listen wait for your
opportunity to speak you know and then
have some humility tell some humility
and have a sense of humor and then they
move closer towards you and you have a
nice and that's the thing I loved about
the the kids segment oh yes those
children they don't know
I am they thought it was just some weird
clown from another world Lagoon
they don't speak the language and they
don't know who I am and by just acting
like an ass we all had a good time yeah
and and so to me that was those are two
of my favorite segments yeah I think I
think we actually we actually have a
photo of you dancing with the children
at Ecole nouvelle Zoran Jay there it is
right there and yeah I mean it was
amazing you just jump right in you had
the girls do your hair a little bit they
got to touch your hair today yeah they
were fascinated by this and they were
tying a ribbon yeah it felt like cloth
and they were tying them in because
that's what they have and they just and
then they started you can see in the
show too they just started like what is
this Jessie first met me she was like
what is it yeah I have if you've never
gone camping and eating spam that's for
a freckled ham that's what I look like
and these kids were just you can so it's
also kind of they were looking at me
like I had fallen to earth and they're
like so speaking of Lewis who who is our
translator here we had let Lipton
Lambert was our translator yes yeah he's
on camera line Lew Lewis did an amazing
job and you mentioned the school kids we
there's a sim prompt to the kids are
asking Conan questions of the band and
our art race leader on the ground
translated a lot of it but there's a lot
of things that kids are saying and we're
like what we just edited in fat cuz it's
like what are they saying and we sent it
to Bow Wow Lew and he sent back a
transcript of all these amazed
just some of my favorite in the show is
because it starts with you playing with
kids and it's all very it's almost
silent comedy and then you get to the
point where you're outside the car there
touching your arm and suddenly they
start responding with some hard-hitting
question yeah
but we didn't like this stuff about you
talking about the president and when go
goes don't worry about him don't let him
bother you and then she goes maybe he
felonies yes there were so and I love
the they weren't afraid to say you know
my dad or my uncle says you're here to
take our stuff cuz I thought Americans
do and you think well this is good it's
good for them to have the first of all
I'm glad that they're saying what they
really think
and I'm telling them I'm not going to
take your stuff and there's they asked
what did the president say about us that
I didn't tell them what I said I said
look he said some stuff but I didn't
want to tell them because it's I don't
think adults adults shouldn't have to
hear that and certainly children
shouldn't but I liked that as quickly
done as that show was I love the
immediacy of it there was such a there
was such a quality of these people's
feelings have been hurt
let's go down there and see if we can
maybe do some good in a small way with
humility and that was a nice feeling
diplomacy through humility uh Jose as a
veteran of so many travel shows coke on
YouTube ass it's hard to do comedy when
there's a language gap and how do you
and you know so
[Laughter]
no way it's funny because there is a
segment where we invite the Haitians to
slam back at Trump right and so when we
were writing that with with the help of
another writer Brian Kylie we you know
it was it was great because at first you
know Trump is a kind of an easy target
Lee everybody can make fun of them but
but to have them make fun of our
president I thought was yeah something
that maybe they don't have an
opportunity to do as much and so yeah
writing jokes was was fun because it
seemed to have a point right you know
they were reacting they had a chance to
react to what had been said about them
by our presidents absolutely yeah he's
rewarding that's yeah I got I got a say
you know one of the one of the great
things too is that I feel it crosses all
boundaries of language everything is
food and natural nation on Twitch asked
how is the food how is the food is
really good
we it was amazing it's that it's very
simple I in the ashes yeah I mean is we
have the same thing to be true in in
Cuba which is it you know I think here
in the United States we can get a little
spoiled or used to this idea that you
can have sushi one night and you can
have Thai the next night you know then
you can have a turkey dinner with you
know I mean it's all over the map and
they're there working with these very
simple ingredients but it's delicious
and riots yeah really yeah extremely
fresh and so we had we had a lot of
really good food while we were there and
I know that the last night I was trying
some of the goats you ordered goat stew
Sweeney did you yes yeah and I tried
some of it and I was like yeah that is
really good yeah though it's taste happy
delicious goats oh the goats all were
killed before that tasty actually that
was a that was a night we went to this
restaurant where Conan you got up and
danced and yeah somebody again quieted
the crowd quite a good face back did you
get to jam on guitar no I did and I was
pretty intimidated by that band we had
all incredibly tight band and I thought
the best contribution I can make is to
run as fast as I can
next to them yes and I thank God I keep
in moderately good shape before
that would have any final episode
because because it just I just went and
went and went and went and didn't stop
until the that song ended and boy that's
a band that can keep a song going yeah I
was I would have been it we've defeated
the whole purpose of our mission for me
to jam with them because it would have
dragged them down into the Sweeney you
said before we went you heard how about
the traffic was and the traffic was
intense
yes one of the things we did was maybe
add a little bit to the chaos of the
traffic when Conan decided to get in the
back of a tap-tap right can you talk a
little bit about that whole a remote and
how that went
so for the Xfinity tap Japanese for
those who don't know it's the AXI but
it's a communal taxi and it's called the
tap tap because do you you tap twice
when you want to hop in yes and and then
when you want to get out is you tap once
and and out you go but so so you're it's
kind of like a tiny communal bus yes
absolutely so um well it started off we
were gonna take off and our driver had
wandered away to get lunch we right we
were fighting the sunsets yeah the Sun
was going down yeah and then he came
back and then out an into traffic and it
took a while before people decided to
hop in
yeah I had trouble you know ride for
free and they saw this orange cherry
with a sign that said step into this
dark man and shock
no one in Haiti that interested I think
you know a guy could have been bleeding
out and eating a lift to the hospital
and he would have seen me and said you
know passes yeah I'm good I'm good well
the first guy I got in is cuz he
recognized
yes we didn't understand why we didn't I
said he hopped right in right Giovani
anybody but he said that well Jesse's is
a lawyer and he we were chatting for a
few seconds and I'm sort of saying well
he ain't on and then he went hey man
team Coco which we then learned in in in
there it's a medical term means to
páginas something I always knew that
coined it so I didn't realize he was so
fluent and Creole this is the longest
prank ever played by Tom Hanks's they
call yourself Team Coco what I did my
start which says Team Coco did you ever
get the midterm wire home after the tap
tap row down yes yes yes and just to be
perfectly fair we the driver that was
driving that tap tap that was not his
usual that's true truck yes so he was
driving it was complicated but for for
various reasons we had to switch him out
and use him to drive that car that he
hadn't driven so when the clutch burned
out on the hill I think if the person
who had been driving that who was
supposed to drive it have been driving
it he knew how to work that clutch this
guy really didn't so I wanted to get
that out there because even though it
ended up being really funny
got knocked up the hill that was
American meddling be tapped after die
once again proving that if you just
leave eh
they'd be better off one thing I really
loved I thought was a very poignant part
of the episode is when we went to go
visit the women of dot Haiti female
entrepreneurs who are creating
businesses to help the economy Jesse can
you talk a little bit about that oh no
no I dad I knew I was really inspired
they I mean every single woman we talked
to it was like they you know had maybe
moved to the US as a kid gotten a degree
maybe gotten two degrees worked started
small businesses in the US and they were
all coming back to Haiti to participate
in this rebuilding after the earthquake
and be a part of the economic recovery
and I was so it just really struck me
because I mean the it I think to them it
is a bit of a sacrifice but it's also
the it's they have such a strong love
for their country and wanting to improve
it and I just thought how you know I
feel lacking that in my own life that I
could improve but the the I completely
lost my train of thought there was the
real argument I know it was great there
because a lot of the women I think and
one of the things I think we we heard
and we were in Haiti was and speaking to
your point earlier about how getting
Haiti back on its feet it's kind of like
the people on the ground in Haiti know
what's best for he yes yeah and and
those women seem like like kind you met
this one woman who had come up with this
business for cornflakes
ya know is he credal that's something we
would never think we wouldn't think of
it and first by woman was really
impressive and
just Harvard alumni yeah she's
impressive she graduated from Harvard
and actually is doing cool stuff and
helping the world yeah rather than
mining it of its job the true Conan's
kill yeah sorry no I what I thought was
so impressive about many of these women
is that I think there's another
misconception that everyone wants to
quote escape Haiti yes absolutely and
what's really cool is that so many of
the women that we met at dot were women
that had grown up in Haiti had left they
got an education the United States they
you know had had these incredibly
impressive jobs I believe she worked at
like Goldman Sachs and turned to Goldman
Sachs I think you know she went to like
either Boston University of Boston
College and graduates I mean they do
this really impressive stuff or they go
to the like the Wharton Business School
then they come back to Haiti because
they feel this desire and it's not guilt
they really do want to go back to their
home and they want to contribute and I
think you know all this paranoia people
have that you know these people want to
come here and just live off of our
resources and you think well wait a
minute just about every woman I met at
dot was someone who had come to United
States and then they were going back to
try and help and make Haiti you know a a
profit Center and prove its ability to
export and that woman had come up with a
really cool idea which is at first I was
thinking she was like individual
servings of cornflakes and they're made
locally and they're individual servings
and I thought well why is that important
and she said it's important because all
of the cornflakes we have our imports
they sit on a shelf for a long time they
get stale these individual packets are
the way that Haiti can make the food
yeah and then have it and then she gave
me a package of the cornflakes and with
milk and they are that that's the best
they were fantastically the texture No
a offense to the good people at
Kellogg's but they were just really
great and delicious and I thought yes I
would actually like this to be the way I
have my cereal I would like interview
you know if this was an export that
Haiti had I would be getting my
cornflakes from them because they are
far superior than our cornflakes and
along those lines this is a clinical
question for the group in Lynn David
Lewin Facebook asks what can the world
learn from Haiti or what is unique about
Haiti that they should be spreading to
make the world great and I think maybe
aside from the other women of dot Haiti
like you know investing in your own yeah
those kinds of things is there anything
else that that we really learned from
the Haitians I learned this I think
several times and it was one thing you
can learn on travel shows is that we're
very materialistic as a country and we
tend to think that the key to being
happy is having all this stuff and
certainly I'll admit I like stuff we all
like stuff but you go to these countries
that have very little of what we
consider what we would consider
important to be happy and they're living
lives of dignity and joy and sorrow and
anger and happiness but they're living
these really full beautiful lives and
then you come back home and you're stuck
in traffic in Beverly Hills and you just
look around and everyone's everyone's a
bitter angry and you think there's
that's what I keep taking away is that
they they know that Haiti is beautiful
and and has the capacity to be much more
than it is now they don't need us to
tell them that I think our show was
maybe just a chance to show what's
already there and show who they already
are which is these people that are you
know enormous ly proud they're enormous
ly proud and they have a great deal of
dignity yeah and they're very proud of
their of being the first you know slave
revolt that was really successful
ya know Western Hemisphere they they
through I mean it's an amazing story
slaves went through
off their shackles and defeated Napoleon
at the height of Napoleon's power and
made their own island
they're quite aware that they're amazing
yeah they don't need us to tell them
it's just that I thought that was
beautiful
absolutely yeah there's so many you read
about the history of the Caribbean so
many slave revolts down there that were
suppressed and and so it's so exciting
it's great to have one story where yeah
yeah I'm gonna butcher this name Christa
Stupak she's amazing sorry I would have
said it right yes oh no no a tradition
is we always sample the local brews the
local beer what beer was this trip and
how was it I think we all know you have
prestige beer that's right and how was
it how was it it's very good yeah you
know it's early and there's a lot of it
and I did a quick commercial for
prestige expecting you know a piece of
the action we also had yes exactly they
have really good rum absolutely
excellent rum and at one point they gave
us what's the name of the company I want
to make sure it's right barbecue
barbecue they gave us a 150 year old rum
is a blend of different a blend of
different ages but it was in honor of
their like hundred and fiftieth year and
so it had some 150 year old rum in it
and they gave it to us in this bottle
and the bottle is gorgeous in the bottle
came in a chloride like a velvet
mahogany case and they gave it to me
like Conan this will be in your home and
grace your home you know as you grow
into your own
since an old age you will have this
beautiful rum and you'll have a sip
every now and then or my dear that night
next morning our urine that Davis Steven
ass face what was your favorite moment
Haiti that was not recorded on camera
baby besides that it's so funny like we
we make a policy of kind of shooting
who's that you know this shooting
everything from the moment we got off
the plane we're kind of always shooting
but stuff kind of always falls through
the cracks was was there a moment yes
yes it's gonna it doesn't translate you
won't understand saying it but we were
giving our there was one night when we
were saying with our these we were
staying in this house lovely people put
us up have we given them a shout out yet
jean-marc and it's lovely yeah Verena
another two kids and they have two
beautiful children and they put us up in
their home and they had a nice dinner
for us and we're all sitting at a table
eating this nice dinner and then we
started to give our executive producer
Jeff Ross a hard time about something
and we're getting off hard time and that
came into a sort of a you know well wait
did he really say that or did he not say
that it's a long story it's silly and
pointless the important thing is we
immediately held a trial to trial and we
were calling in witnesses from our
Haitian crew and they were testifying
and they had to put their hand on a
plate and everybody was it was so
beautiful because the hate that the
Haitian people who were helping us out
were crying they were laughing we were
laughing so hard it was this ridiculous
trial for no reason I'm going on it it
kept any sustainably yeah going and
getting funnier and funnier than which
like wait a minute then calling
in that driver in the laughing you say I
cannot say we like you must say and it
was how it's the hardest I've laughed in
memory and it was one of those things
that you even now I can't explain was
just a trial about nothing but everybody
was in on the joke that's right and
there was no hierarchy like you know the
people that were helping us that the
Haitian people who were helping us on
the crew or mocking he was mocking ever
since we used to be a lawyer so yeah if
we get this question every single time
so we're just gonna get it out of the
way now
Anastasia on YouTube asks when or if
will we ever bring Jordan on Conan
without borders
well there's what's that yes we we will
there will be a Jordan will come on a
Conan without borders it's just figuring
and we have what we think is the right
idea it's just getting it all to line up
one of the problems with Jordan is that
his software crashes there and needs to
be sent back by the way Windows this
comes up cuz Jordan sends in this
question every yeah Jordan generated but
you know Jordan is I can't tell you that
everywhere I go you know just
specifically the United States but
everywhere I go people come out of the
woodwork and go I mean I I've been I was
I was like in a in an Out Burger taking
my son in-n-out burger like way north of
Los Angeles I think I were like two
hours north of Los Angeles when we were
going south we were going camping and
and we were coming out of an in-and-out
burger I think and a pickup truck just
screeched to a halt in the middle of the
street and the guy with his engine still
running jumped out of his pickup truck
he came running
it's Jordan for real you see for real
and I said yeah that's crazy and then he
ran back in his truck I was trying to
like roll back
Cesar le ragazze for us does our family
travel with us we take these kinds of
trips no I do my daughter is now she's
14 and I really would love to you know
she I'd have to take her out of school
and that the Haiti trip happens so
quickly but I would love to take her and
and she was fascinated with the Haiti
show and she came to a live taping she's
never been to a live taping before oh
and loved it and loved the Q&A and she's
getting very interested in being she's a
really good person but she's interested
in being a citizen of the world and
trying to help so I could see taking her
on one of these trips my son you know
he's a monster
a lot of people in the chats have asked
how what they can do to help you can go
to Team Coco Tom / Haiti for more
information on that and and for people
who who can't donating to help us but
what are some more some things that
people can do to help Haiti would you
guys say there is there anything besides
donating I mean we owe
besides donate yeah I've made that point
which is there you know Anderson Cooper
regularly vacations in Haiti and loves
it and he's not doing it to be like a
good guy he's doing it because he loves
the people he has a lot of friends there
and it's fascinating it's a fascinating
place with an amazing history and you go
there and you go there and you spend
money and you meet the people and I
think that is and you experience it and
then if you really like it you go back
and that I think that is the most human
way to support a country is to go to
that is to you know and and obviously
donations are in
Fortin but but go to that go to Haiti
yeah well if you can't go to Haiti go to
youtube and check out their history it's
fascinating it affects the US history
and it's it's a great story
yeah Jose wrote though what a minute so
he's he's loaded up with his love it I
loved enjoy I really enjoyed learning a
lot about Haiti and word that I received
somebody in the chat asked earlier what
was the challenge of putting that
together on such quick notice just a
great team that's a really good point
though I so much of the rest of the
world knows our history right yeah and
we I think grow up not knowing that much
about the context of of how of other
countries and how they came to be and
and came to their independent stories so
I do think that that's like
acknowledging those stories and just and
and appreciating them is is really
absolutely and and as someone else in
the chat had asked earlier what has
everyone you know we've we've been to a
lot of these countries now we've done I
think this was our seven Travel Show and
you know what is the sense that you guys
have gotten about what uh what the rest
of the world thinks of America what have
you learned from hearing other people's
opinions outside the US I want to tackle
that one Jose yeah I was gonna say that
one
one thing we've heard a lot I mean this
is in the last year that we've been
traveling since we've had our president
but I think other countries are a lot
more understanding of the the idea that
you can disagree with your leader and
that that what a leader says maybe isn't
representative of how the entire country
feels and so I think people have been
really generous it is that's true yeah
you sense you know almost every time
we've taken there's some slack they cut
us some slack and and there's also a lot
of countries do have an appreciation
I think Americans can maybe even
justifiably feel weary sometimes they
think we you know I'm very optimistic
about America and I think most Americans
are good generous people I look around
this room and I'm saddened but well I
think outside of this room averages low
for this cash we've brought the average
down no I I sincerely believe that most
Americans want to want to do good and
I've always been you know to quote some
country west to sing or proud to be an
American I think we've done I think
we've tried I do think that we you know
the average American person would rather
do good than do ill and I think that
there is an appreciation of that in the
world when we've traveled there you know
they do people do appreciate that for
the most part I think Americans have or
America has tried you know in some ways
and yes they see us for all our warts
and flaws and of course their areas of
the world where they're always gonna
hate us but they might I know maybe
they're just being polite to us I guess
they feel like overall more optimistic
than not yeah well it is that one-on-one
thing where you just fall yeah you know
II just been new people and learning
about a culture you we always come away
with just so you say our Haiti cycling
Lolita yeah it just feels wrong with
chewing gum yeah you kind of get the
sense that all everyone's kind of the
same we're all kind of this we're all
very different
don't ever summarise like that again
your summaries are terribly are I'm not
so what you're saying
Mulk know thing is that we're all
gluten-free no Lars Lars and you
almost actually a lot of times I get
your question that now but Lars I need
to ask Conan that moment when the kids
asked you what the president said about
them made me cry how did you maintain
your composure throughout that and other
emotional moments well I have no
emotional course no I did I just it was
you know I have children and when they
ask you a hard question you you know it
it's a bit of a I think what's nice
about that moment is again it's very
real I'm not going to tell those kids
I'm not gonna repeat what was said and I
don't want them ever to hear that and
then it just upon reflection immediately
makes me sad that that that they would
even that they would hear it yeah and
but you know you just had to yeah I just
think in that moment just I don't know
be a dad talking to kids you know that's
that's I'm a dad so try and protect them
somewhat from the baseness of the world
instead of the cruelty of the world just
not you know I don't want them to hear
that but I do want them to know the
reality that we have this president that
occasionally says things that you you
know and I love that girl's reaction
that she just sort of company off as
like I don't worry about him something's
wrong that guy they must have dropped
him on his head I know and that's cool
again it was I I think leaving Haiti it
was such a sense of hope because
organizations like Pro Jeb who run that
school that was for the poorest
communities yet to send their children
for free yes you think in 20 years how
many kids will have gone through that
school getting such a great education
and it's nice too because that's where
you know when I got back from Haiti the
first thing I didn't talk to my wife and
you know she we both agreed immediately
that that's where we wanted our donation
to go was was to that school and that
makes it personal
there's something about sometimes you'll
just be watching TV and they'll say if
you want to help you know right you know
and just swipe your credit card and
there's not this connection but when
you've been there and you've met the
students and you've seen what they're
doing and I feel like like an alumni
that I'm invested now and I I do think
that that's something that enriches me
it Rin riches it enriched us to go to
Haiti absolutely I think we did not go
there to quotes you know to save the
world or do anything heroic we went
there to meet the people and we were
enriched by it yeah or that we were the
winners and you know they're probably
regretting it and a long kind of those
same lines Ian Brady asks what was the
hardest thing we witnessed while in
Haiti what would you guys say the
hardest thing one you know we go on all
these trips and and it does kind of feel
like a whirlwind because we're there so
quickly and we're working like 18 hours
a day and it kind of doesn't really sink
in until later the things we experienced
and that stuff was there anything in
particular that stood out to you that
was that was tough I mean there is there
is a lot of poverty it's uh it like a
lot of countries in the world um I mean
you know comparatively when you come
from what the richest country in the
world and you're seeing people live in a
much different way but I also I mean I I
think I really appreciate like people
there were so generous to us and and I
find that often to the people with less
are more generous with what they have
yeah yeah and that's really that really
affected me I would say to me the
saddest thing is that you see things in
life that break your heart and there's
nothing that you can do about it
right and you see people that whether
it's a person with an ailment or you
know and there's just or there's a
disaster and there's nothing you can do
about it and it doesn't just you know I
think the saddest thing to me about
Haiti and about other countries as well
I think in the 21st century
with all the technology that we have
and all the wealth there is worldwide
poverty is increasingly becoming it's
not necessary it doesn't have to exist
on that level that's right and when
you're in Haiti you see this gorgeous
island beautiful smart creative people
and they've been not treated well by the
Western Hemisphere or actually they've
been that they have not been treated
well yeah first by colonial powers you
know their own leaders and then their
own the heirs at times and you know we
they've we've not been always the best
friends to them and it's what seems I'm
it feels unnecessary that's what gets me
mostly you're driving around and you're
thinking I do believe this these issues
are solvable absolutely don't think that
people have to live in this kind of
poverty and I think this could be this
could be addressed and there's a lot of
smart people in the world and with and
there's so much wealth in this country
concentrated in absurd places that if
some small bit of that was diverted
sometimes here and there people's lives
would be completely different
yeah the great it was hard to reconcile
the poverty you're talking about with
the everyone we were meeting that
because they were so vibrant and and
wonderful and and smart and in hard it
was hard to reconcile the two realities
yeah Emily on YouTube asks I wonder if
those kids play drums on their desk all
the time now I know I really do think
that they were sort of shocked when they
were doing it and then they loved it and
I swear they're doing it right now and I
said making it word the third time then
you get up yeah yes now you don't even
have to stay your side they all go I
counted running around I kept and
my experience is that I attack the tiny
child ruiner
because I love to goof around the kid I
always have and I'm very childlike when
I'm around kids and then they always
want more more and again and then I'm
always getting parents later on saying
you know thanks a lot because they're
all yeah now they think it's funny to
light the curtains on we live time for
two more questions and one of them I
don't need to discuss it on camera but
Stephen Simon's who is the easiest
person to travel with let me started on
our show in 90s I think it's true in 93
as an intern no no maybe a little later
but pretty he was there I mean right yes
we've been around 25 years and so maybe
he's been there 23 so he's brand-new
hahaha but he he is an absolute you know
I can't imagine any incarnation of this
show late night tonight Conan he is you
know he is the heart of the whole matter
and he's just an indispensable part of
the show and he's a warrior he's just
where he gets things done you know you
just wherever you are and I've been with
him in so many different parts of the
world and he's always there like hey
friend and he hands me like a cup of
coffee when I'm cold a cold drink when
I'm hot or tells me your makeup is
running down your face in your eyes but
but everyone else we work with in these
countries they all fall in love with him
yeah yeah that's true these are scenes I
would say he's a secret weapon JC celeb
and yet he's also the worst yeah there
we go
Persephone humping the Omega yeah all
right Harry on YouTube ass and a lot of
other people in asking and they always
ask any idea where we're going next do
we have any idea
I can say actually we usually dodge this
question yes we usually die I don't
think I'm gonna dodge the question we
will pretty soon be leaving to go to
India so we're going to go to India and
[Music]
no way that we wanted to go to India for
a long time and actually it was
scheduled before we went to Haiti Haiti
was an improvised trip we're going
really soon and we would love it is
gonna be a very but will be coming very
soon and we would love suggestions we'd
like to meet people when we're there we
are we've we've I mean this came about
very organically because I was invited
to India right yes I by vir das a a very
funny comedian who's been on our show
and we're really excited to go just
cannot miss chomping at the bit to get a
tea and it's shocking but we're going
really really soon yes sooner than your
leaving here yes so I know but you know
we will be we will be you know like I
say the purpose of these trips is to
make friends and so if you're watching
now and you're living in India we're
told it's a very small country
we've don't want to research yet but you
probably run into us told ya it's about
the population of Delaware and no we're
really thrilled to go and and feel like
this could be a fantastic whoa what was
that
disco already changing to India we're
just morning pyrotechnics that's falling
down again yes thank you all for joining
us for this lot of Q&A that's right
thank you all for joining us a YouTube
Facebook and Twitter to go to tea
koco.com slash Haiti for our full
episode a whole bunch of web extras
thank you knows a Mike Jesse and Conan
of course and we will see you guys in
India thank you guys
you